culture clash the price of protecting
the Arts in the interview Monica gutters
from the German parliamentary committee
on culture hope are not America Europe
and North America want to grow closer
economically and talks are underway
aimed at creating a major free trade
agreement between the EU in the US but
there's one conflict right from the
start and that's the question of culture
the Europeans are worried that culture
will be trampled on if its treated as a
commodity in global free trade so they
want to keep culture out of it most
glitters why make an exception for
cultures none vive adinda because of the
dual character of culture which on the
one hand provides a service and is
recognized as a legitimate commercial
good but on the other hand must be
protected as a carrier of core cultural
values and these values should not be
sacrificed for the sake of commercial
interests and market liberalisation
darsana germany and france of the
driving force behind this demand but
there are many more countries in the EU
a countries working together closely
behind the scenes or is everyone acting
to protect their own interests first I
courtois angular as far as culture is
concerned they're working together
because culture only makes up two
percent of the volume of trade between
Europe and America each country on its
own would make only a marginal
contribution so they do work together on
this issue but France and Germany are
indeed the driving force behind efforts
to exclude culture from the Free Trade
Agreement here in Germany government's
support for the Arts and the idea of
culture is so strong that we tend to
overshadow the other European countries
including France Germany is the country
with the biggest concentration of
theaters 10 times as many people go to
museums than to all the bundesliga
soccer matches combined a new book is
published here for every 1,000
inhabitants half of the world's
orchestras play in Germany you despite a
Internet's on a dorkus auf deutsch on
board and speared so we have more to
defend here than fiscal trivialities and
we're concerned about the whole picture
and not just single economic sectors
like film subsidies
swagga very firm fertile but mi carnal
the Americans as well as the British
government see culture is more of a
commercial product or a competitive
product that's why they accused the
Europeans of distorting competition by
calling for a cultural exception to free
trade don't they have a point and the
culture is after all a commercial
activity i'ma tell ya Decorah Laurah
dozen people in the arts are aware of
the advantages of free trade agreement
would provide and they defend it on
those grounds but this is really about
the two percent of values that don't
have a chance of competing on the market
because they are troublesome forms of
expression that provide a critical
corrective to society especially in
Germany culture is anything but
affirmative and that's why we subsidize
it here so it holds a mirror up to
society and makes us uncomfortable at
times it's this cultural diversity the
spirit of culture that shapes Germany
that we are defending here but that
doesn't mean we're uninterested in
improving conditions for the creative
industries by doing away with trade
barriers that goes without saying
creative industries are one thing and
the spirit of culture is a defining
element of Germany's national culture is
another deutschland plaguing this
element at school true not see us under
them as a quick torture without
subsidies is unthinkable in Germany just
look at the German theater scene with
its 150 to 160 theaters every seat is
subsidized to the tune of 100 to 150
euros every ticket what would happen if
these subsidies dried up Dawson glebe
naturally Germany lives off the richness
of a legacy left behind by the old
principalities that split Germany up
into many small principalities but at
the same time we're trying to promote an
element of avant-garde and that requires
adequate state funding we also believe
that by encouraging artists and
intellectuals to take the lead in our
culture that is avant-garde at its best
a history of two dictatorships has
taught us that it's our duty to
immediately confront any kind of
totalitarian impulses and the best way
to do that is to let free spirits roam
by offering them such things as
government-funded social insurance for
artists special tax arrangements and
copyright protection
as well as other tax advantages that
make them feel less constrained this
free thinking element provides our
society with so much diversity we
believe it has eliminated any
dictatorial or totalitarian impulses
that could now threaten us that is what
we are defending and longing of a
graphite Susan does this as phosphatidyl
until a substantial amount of our highly
subsidized cultural life is dedicated to
remembering and working through our
troubled past and all of that would be
eliminated or ignored if we didn't try
to protect our funding of the Arts from
liberalizing tendencies often took photo
shoots and for citing Lieberthal easy on
stones and so didn't find any of these
free thinkers are found in the
literature scene literature production
in Germany has long been supported by
price-fixing agreements for books is
this now threatened Zenzi do you fear
that yea high spin your globe yes I
believe that fixed book prices are under
threat that's true for the domestic
market in Europe and throughout the
world but of course this is a concrete
point of negotiation in a free trade
agreement the wide variety of high
quality literary publications offered by
so many publishers in Germany is only
possible because of cross subsidization
with bestsellers and if it all ended up
like any other business many of these
small publishers that devote themselves
to high quality literature would go
under because they could no longer
afford the cross subsidization if big
sellers like Amazon no longer had to
comply with barriers and fix book prices
especially on the internet that would be
the end of diverse and high quality
literature in Germany book sifting
muster there's no other country that
publishes one new book for every
thousand inhabitants that would be
seriously threatened I nails for finding
others like I miss filagra scone that's
where a photography added your phone
that probably since we're talking about
publishing let's discuss copyright laws
they're also threatened by digital media
the film industry the press of course
and the music industry have all been
battling piracy what can the cultural
exception to free trade do here as of
your fighting We strongly defend
copyrights here Inge
Germany we know that artists and
creative people need to be able to live
off their services and that means we
have to make their work accessible and
make sure they get paid for what they do
but this self-service mentality on the
internet along with the big commercial
machines starting with Google on up to a
bookseller like Amazon represent a real
danger to the livelihood of many artists
here ethnic afar for EXO so in that
respect our copyright laws defend the
role of the authors artists creators and
intellectuals and that's true for the
sciences as well we still have a lot to
do in that area and things look very
different in other countries with the
various parties within Germany and not
always in agreement here part I Linus
critic critics of the cultural exception
to free trade say it would merely create
a breeding ground for sub cultures that
are only accessible to elite shouldn't
the ants be judged by their success
queefed under there's a focused it does
tune via that's what we do every year
when we pass a new budget and by the way
our cultural committees do nothing else
that asked whether the services that we
subsidize and make possible with
taxpayers money are justifiable but I
have to add that we have an average
capacity of eighty-four percent at the
more than 800 venues in Germany that is
certainly positive feedback and it can't
be the result of elites alone on the
other hand most of our funding goes
toward cultural education and we
shouldn't forget how important that is
people are entitled to such benefits as
good as any court or lob dog bust us out
of ten times as many people visit
museums then go to all bundesliga soccer
matches that justifies putting barely
one-point-seven percent of tax revenues
into funding for the Arts in Germany
it's no more than that and it will still
have a national culture that the world
recognizes Cynthia D quote or nuts aw
nuts diva verified Fagin on then the
birthday the concept of a national
culture comes from the 19th century
before Germany was united as a nation
back then language and culture was seen
as uniting forces but does Germany still
have this view of itself today do we
still care about having a national
culture in the age of globalization and
digital media kuttawa not seein Allah
definite
been feeling of it until I spent a lot
of time in other countries especially as
a representative of German culture and
it's always been the case that people
are downright envious of us Germans
because of the variety of our culture
the quantitative variety of course but
also the aesthetic variety we are seen
as a country where the made in Germany
label does indeed make us a valuable
trading partner and we do have a good
reputation for the quality of our
products but the second characteristic
is our national culture people see and
respect the serious way we deal with our
past they respect our transparency and
the ruthlessness of our self criticism
but people have also learned that by
defending the major freedoms the freedom
of opinion artistic expression religion
and freedom of assembly more than almost
any other country Germany has set an
example when it comes to democracy and
that is how our national culture
expresses itself today the number of our
theatres is one thing but these are the
building blocks of our freedom and it's
our job to protect them by making our
artists independent through state
subsidies independent from sponsors
independent from the latest trends and
tastes they don't have to try and please
everyone with their work instead they
are actually encouraged to throw a light
in our society to make us reflect on
things even if it makes us feel
uncomfortable sonaze ver de nada to a
muti stones at was fought so few of us
on the magazine after all only by doing
this have we overcome our past and
regained our standing in the world
following the collapse of our
civilization during the Third Reich
otters threat in the face and that's
what i mean by our national culture
darwin Gators bamboo cliff Dakota not
soon there's a clown that was a clear
answer let's end with a look to the
future Alice the issue of cultural
exception has been provisionally removed
from the free trade negotiations does
that mean the sword of Damocles is still
hanging over the arts yard haces a shana
i would say it does we are now in the
preliminary phase at the start of
negotiations and that's why many
business representatives are saying you
cannot start off by creating at a booth
that we say if we don't do it now it
will get even more difficult later on
first of all when
dealing with 2% of the trade volume but
the identity of our society is also
involved and that's why it has to be
possible these are not tactical games
we're playing here but rather the fact
that 14 culture ministers wrote a letter
to EU negotiators saying that this
cultural exception applies to all of us
and that will be carried into the next
phase of negotiations with great
seriousness I'm grateful to France for
energetically insisting on the cultural
exception which it did an agreement with
its economics Minister in Germany we're
still carrying on with the classic
conflict between the economy here and
culture there but in the end I'm sure
that our community of shared values will
win out over mercantile interests
mcentee and in person I'm endodontic
rest area oh thank you for talking to us
miss glitters